sie wetten auch sieg oder niederlage auf
die fußballspiele vom nächsten
wochenende
sie sind gerade 18 und dürfen ganz legal
zocken
je höher die quote desto mehr können sie
gewinnen
ich kann maximal
106 euro gewinnen und habe zwei euro
eingesetzt ich habe getippt in der
französischen liga das paris gewinnt der
günstige habe ich auf wolfsburg getippt
und ich habe ziemlich wieder in der
englischen liga getippt und vielleicht
noch vierte liga deutschland
genau hier im brandenburgischen rathenow
punktspielen am vierten liga
regionalliga
nicht nur auf hoch bezahlte profis kann
gewettet werden auch auf amateure so
ganz sicher können sich die fans deshalb
nicht sein
einzelne spieler könnten das match in
eine richtung lenken oder der
schiedsrichter
weil sie bezahlt wurden von jemandem der
viel geld auf ein ganz bestimmtes
ergebnis getippt hat
bei diesem spiel natürlich reine
spekulation doch theoretisch möglich
also ich denke mal dass es schon möglich
ist dass
einigen spielern vielleicht mal was
angeboten wird aber ich sage mal auf
welche sachen sind wir hier noch nicht
untergekommen jeder macht alles für geld
werde es so auf den fußball es wäre
jetzt nicht in ordnung
wäre
die jungen wetter im wettbüro
interessieren sich mehr für ihre tipps
als für die neuesten enthüllungen im
wettskandal
das vor einer woche wurde der aufgedeckt
380 manipulierte spiele in 15 ländern
europas wohl nur die spitze des
eisberges aber allein damit sollen die
betrüger acht millionen euro verdient
haben für die anbieter der sportwetten
ist der skandal geschäftsschädigend
stefan meurer ist chef von 860 watt
filialen des unternehmens tipico jeder
betrüger schadet nicht nur dem image ich
muss die zeche zahlen weil er versucht
ja diese wetten bei mir zu platzieren um
dann den gewinn natürlich bei mir
abzuholen deswegen sind wir oft die
leidtragenden
und deswegen ist auch jedes wort wird
unternehmen gut beraten seine eigene
risikosysteme natürlich zu entwickeln
und auch zu betreiben und permanent
natürlich zu überwachen
fußballwetten sind die beliebtesten
sportwetten
sie sind einst aus der wettbranche im
pferderennen entstanden
und zwar in england dort wo heute die
professionellen kontrolleure sitzen
die analysten des unternehmens
sportradar spüren weltweit
spielmanipulationen auf sie prüfen
53.000 partien jedes jahr
auch bei vielen der aktuellen
betrugsfälle haben sie alarm geschlagen
einen dietz wenn sich quoten plötzlich
ändern bei zucker gezielt große mengen
geld einsetzen etwa auf ein
torverhältnis so der deutsche
sicherheitsmanager dass die betrüger im
vorfeld kennen ein favorit spiel zu
hause gegen einen außenseiter führt nach
fünf minuten 10
das spiel geht 10 aus dass uns alle als
wunderbar der favorit wieder gewonnen
aber im wettmarkt wurde das spiel
manipuliert und zwar von der favoriten
mannschaft die das spiel so dominiert
hat dass sie wusste dass sie mit nicht
mehr als einem oder maximal zwei toren
gewinnt
was beim wetten alles möglich ist haben
diese vier gar nicht auf dem schirm wohl
aber dass man auf alles wetten kann wir
haben schon überlegt aus ägyptischen
volleyball zu werden oder auch
organische hunderennen
allerdings
es sind die quoten stehen nicht so gut
wie gar nicht
in wirklichkeit aber bleiben sie bei
ihren fußballwetten jetzt müssen die nur
noch stimmen